I have a lot of faith in in my fellow
human beings I have this doesn't mean
that there are not people who
occasionally will disappoint you when
you have faith in them and they fail to
deliver or you find that their duplicity
you find that a fair amount i would say
too much far too much and it is very
disappointing on the other hand I I
think that if you go into a situation
with a skeptical or a cynical view about
humanity that is going to be so evident
to everyone around you that you will not
be very successful in achieving anything
really so I've I think basically human
nature is good and positive and
constructive and the second I think that
most of what's happened in society over
the medium and long term has been for
the good not that there are not horrible
things the Holocaust World War two you
know the the kind of killings that went
on in in Cambodia and are going on in
Darfur there are some horrible things
people are capable of enormous brutality
toward their fellow human beings it is a
terrible thing but if you look at the
march of humanity if you look at how
much progress there has been made over
the last four or five thousand years you
know there is the society by and large
has more opportunity available for the
average citizen the average citizen
lives far better today in the United
States then 50 or 100 years ago lower
income people have medical care that
they would not have had even 50 years
ago education has given more and more
people opportunity that they perhaps
wouldn't have had we now have
as a result of the civil rights movement
blacks in this country who while there
is still some measure of discrimination
far far less than then in the past
that's an enormous change we don't
realize how how far we've come in a
short period of time growing up in
baltimore as i mentioned schools were
segregated when i was little we it's
unheard of people can't even imagine
that that could be the case but it was
and and therefore and if you look at
other countries look at China China
people there were people have complaints
China's doing this doing that but the
the improvement in the economy of China
has catapulted millions and millions
hundreds of millions of people into
higher living standards the same is true
in India the same is true in many
developing countries fifty years ago a
large portion of the developing world
were colonies there now independent
countries some are successes some are
failures but nonetheless they're
independent they have the opportunity to
chart their own destinies there are a
whole lot of things that have given me
the sense that that that that humanity
is is is better off in general
individually there are a lot of people
who are suffering if they're in Darfur
if they lived in Cambodia if they've
lived in places like this in Bob way if
they live in Iran and under this
fundamentalist regime if they're victims
of groups like the Taliban if they're
victims of terrorism I mean there are a
lot of people who live very desperate
lives precarious lives insecure lives so
it certainly doesn't mean that all is
well in the world it is not all from
most many people things can be very bad
but but the general thrust of
civilization has improved opportunity
improved longevity improved diets
improved education and and that that's
positive and one can help but think that
that process has the opportunity to go
on but leadership is required to ensure
that
does go on
hey